it began back in November of 1985 when
hunter came across a barrel near Bear
Brook State Park inside the barrel two
bodies that of an adult female and young
girl that she was related to then 15
years later another barrel was
discovered about a hundred yards from
the first inside that barrel the bodies
of two young girls one of whom was
related to the woman officials say that
all four died from blunt force trauma
and were bound in a similar fashion
there's no 13 oh clock
[Music]
hey there and welcome to episode 74 of
the 13 o'clock podcast this is gonna be
kind of an unusual episode I'm going to
be flying solo this time around if any
of you saw the post that I made I posted
on the blog and I posted on the Facebook
page and on Twitter and things like that
Tom actually had a family emergency and
he had to fly to Mississippi to visit
his father who was going to be having
quadruple bypass surgery so he kind of
took a last-minute flight I'm recording
this on Saturday so he took the
last-minute flight last night and got
there last night
so he's going to be spending the next
week with his dad and his family and
hopefully that will all go very well so
we kind of thought about not doing the
episode just like skipping a week and
stuff like that but I was like you know
I already researched all this this
week's topic and everything so I figured
you know I can just do one by myself and
who knows I might even just like stick
in some old footage of Tom from other
shows like making funny comments or
something like that we'll see how it
goes
man and I might actually also have to do
our weekly movie review by myself -
because I don't he's not gonna be back
until the Friday after this episode
comes out so that might be just me - so
I might take that opportunity to do a
David Lynch movie he because he doesn't
like those so much so so I'm gonna do
one by myself so I can just like squee
about David Lynch all I want and he
won't make fun of me
so anyway we have a pretty cool show
it's a true-crime extravaganza you know
how much I love those gonna talk about
the Caddy murders gonna talk about the
bear Brook murders which actually I
start I hadn't I hadn't been researching
those for a while but when I researched
them for the show it turns out that
there have actually been a lot of
developments in that case in the past
couple of years and they think they
might have solved it so we'll get into
that a little bit too and of course
we're gonna do our current events
segment also which is also a true crime
related so it all kind of goes together
and I like when that happens before we
do that I'm gonna do the regular shout
outs my book the faceless villain
obvious
is still out if you're into true crime
and you want to read a compilation of
all the unsolved creepy true crimes that
happened between 1900 and 1959 then that
is available I still have some codes for
the oddity of books if you would like a
free copy of the audiobook just get in
touch with me on youtube or send me your
email and I will get you a code I still
have a few left and thank you to all the
people that have requested them so far
and I've written reviews of the book and
stuff like that that's really really
much appreciated and you'll be happy to
know that I've been working on the
second volume which is going to cover
murders from 1960 to 1980 so I'm you
know right in the fifth chapter of that
and I'm hoping to get that out before
summertime like sometime in the spring
I'm kind of shooting for so we'll see
how that goes the audio book may take
longer obviously because you know it's
more technical [ __ ] and all that
other kind of stuff but we'll see and
I'm really trying to work on it and get
it done so I can get it out of here also
we just did a movie review for the 1979
TV mini-series Salem's Lot featuring the
very very scary Kurt Barlow vampire and
also that creepy scene with the kid
floating outside the window so go check
that out if you haven't already like I
said our next movie review will probably
just may but we'll see how it goes and
it'll probably be a David Lynch movie
because you know those because that's
the one that I wanted to do and I feel
like Tom kind of didn't want to do it
and kept putting it off so that'll
probably be the next one we do so keep
an eye out for that also as always if
you liked the show would like to support
it then you can check out our patreon
page at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast if you do not like patreon and
would like to make a one-time or monthly
or whatever donation using PayPal then
you can do that as well you can go to
our blog at 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there is a link right
there in the sidebar to a PayPal account
that will support the show also and I
think I mentioned this in the last
couple episodes this will probably be
the last time I mention it but starting
with our new shows in 2018 we're also
starting to put the names of all our
patrons and donors and stuff like that
in the credits of the show or in the
descriptions of the audio podcast so
that's another
extra added perk there if you're into
that now let's get into our current
event now this is actually a story that
goes back to the 90s but it's kind of
current in the news because this dude
just went on trial again for yet another
series of murders now apparently this is
one of the world's worst serial killers
if he gets convicted of these murders
that he's standing trial for now he's
not real
since he's Russian I guess he's not real
known in America because I had really
never heard of him or only vaguely heard
of him and his name is mikhail pop cough
and he is known as the werewolf murderer
or the wednesday murderer also known as
the anger maniac that's what the russian
media calls him so this guy the BBC
reported on January 10th that this guy
is going on trial again now he was
already serving a life sentence in
Russia he was convicted in 2015 of
murdering 22 women or 24 women the
sources kind of differ on that and he
confessed to all of those and stuff like
that now turns out that this trial that
he's undergoing now it's because he
confessed to an additional 60 murders
which if you're not good at math his
total that would bring his total to more
than 80 victims which damn holy [ __ ] I
mean he's really a bad dude and the
creepiest thing about him is that he got
away with it for a really long time
because he seemed like a normal dude and
also cuz he was a cop
so he would kind of you know he would
drive around in his cop car in his cop
uniform and stuff like that and he would
you know lure people into his car that
way because you know they thought oh
he's a cop and it's safe and stuff like
that he's like yeah I'll Drive you home
to safety and then no he would rape and
kill them yeah this guy is horrifying so
like I said if he gets convicted of
these murders that he's on trial for now
that just started in January then
that'll be Oh
over 80 people all of them women except
I think he killed one man but other than
that all women almost all raped also
some of them were cut up dismembered all
kinds of [ __ ] like that and he actually
kind of got his start in around 1992 in
and around Siberia around or Koontz that
city and like I said he's been a cop
there for a really long time he was a
cop until 1998 and even after that I you
know he was still using his cop thing is
like a way to lure victims now the first
murder he committed I mean to hear him
tell it it almost seems kind of like he
thought of it as sort of like a lark
like he had this woman in his car and
he's kind of like gee I think I'll rape
and kill this chick kind of thing and
then evidently I guess he developed a
taste for it and started doing it over
now the reason that he gives is that he
was one of these dudes that was like
well he didn't agree with women going
out to bars or going out to clubs
without their husbands or boyfriends
like going out unaccompanied or just
going out with their girlfriends or
whatever so he had that thing where he
thought he was punishing them he was
quote-unquote cleansing the streets of
prostitutes which you know whatever and
so yeah he was doing that kind of thing
he would like kind of use his patrol car
he would like lurk around bars or
whatever and see women that were coming
out of places that were kind of
inebriated and he'd be like hey I'm a
cop I'll give you a ride home safely
and you know they would be like okay
fine and then he would get in the car
you drive him to some remote location in
the woods and he would rape and kill
them usually used an axe or a knife or
you know whatever was around and stuff
like that now he was doing this for a
while and he only got caught because
this one girl that he had picked up and
I think she was only 15 at the time he
picked her up and he took her out in the
woods and he threw her against a tree
like bashed her head against a tree and
knocked her unconscious or partly
unconscious and then started to rape her
now he left her for dead and it was
freezing cold she was naked all this
other kind of
but she lived and they found her the
next day she was like walking around she
walked and got help and she all she
could remember she couldn't really
remember what he looked like very well
but she did remember that he was a cop
so at that point you know the
authorities were like well all the cops
in this area have to give us DNA so they
got them to do that and they got this
[ __ ] DNA and they're like hey it's
you
now the creepiest thing about this too
is that this dude has a wife and his
wife also was in law enforcement she
worked for the police also it's really
not known they don't think that she was
in on it or that she even knew what he
was doing now she did give him an alibi
a couple of times like when they were
like well where was he at this night
she's like oh he was with me or
something that one he wasn't but they're
not real clear about if she knew she
seemed super shocked because she said he
always seemed like a normal person he
was a good husband he had a daughter
they had a daughter you know he was a
good father all this other stuff
yeah the daughter is a schoolteacher and
in a lot of ways the wife and the
daughter still kind of in denial you
know the daughter has even been quoted I
think she was quoted I think it was in
the siberian times where you know she
was saying I really don't think it was
him he seemed like a normal guy we did
normal dad daughter stuff you know she's
like if it was him I'd like to be able
to look him in the face and have him
tell me that he really did do it and
maybe then I would believe it but the
whole story is just horrible and it's
like I couldn't even imagine like if you
were with somebody for a really long
time look cuz they'd been married a very
long time I mean the the daughters grown
she's in her 20s and you know to find
out that not only is your husband and
dad a serial killer but he's like one of
the worst serial killers in history he's
just going around he's killed at least
80 people that they know of and maybe
more and he doesn't seem super
remorseful about it it must be said he
just kind of seems like yeah it's just
something I do i I punish them he's like
oh I tried to cover up the crimes
because I knew it was illegal I'm like
oh yeah really okay so it's just a
horrifying horrifying story like I said
one of the world's worst serial killers
Russian fella
Kayle pop cough go and look that [ __ ] up
there's not he doesn't even have a
Wikipedia page not in English anyway not
that I could find he there is a thing
about him on murder PDA where there's
several articles about him and [ __ ] like
that
I had actually never really heard of him
until I looked into this story you know
for the news segment and stuff like that
and the dude is just horrifying and
creepy looking and I just can't deal
with it
so that'll do it for the news portion of
the episode so let's get into the main
topics of the episode like I said it's
kind of a true-crime extravaganza so you
know if the [ __ ] about the werewolf
killer wasn't horrifying enough then
just stay tuned it gets worse but anyway
so the first thing we're gonna talk
about is the infamous Teddy murders now
this was actually a request although it
was on my list already because it was
it's a case that I've always been kind
of fascinated with and it's one that
seems to have captured the public
imagination it seems to have turned up
on a lot of like creepiest unsolved
murders cases and stuff like that
now this crime took place in 1981 in a
little bitty town called Ketty it's a
resort community in Northern California
about 87 miles from Reno now evidently
it used to be kind of a swing in place
you know a lot of people would go there
for you know for vacations and they
would rent these little cabins and stuff
like that but by the time the 80s rolled
around people didn't really come there
anymore for vacation and stuff like that
so they had started renting the cabins
out to low income families which was
actually kind of working out because it
was a nice place to raise a family it
was safe and you know it was reasonably
priced and stuff like that so pretty
much all the cabins were permanently
rented out by families so the trouble
occurred on April 21st 1981 now the
woman that lived in the cabin was named
Glenna sue sharp usually known as sue
and she had five children she was 36
years old so she was at home in the
cabin which is famously cabin number 28
she was in the house also in the house
was two of her kids Ricky and Greg who
were 10 and 5 respectively also a friend
of theirs named Justin she also had a 12
year old daughter Tina who was home she
had another daughter named Sheila who
was 14 she was actually staying with
neighbors at the cat either the cabin
next door the second
down now she also had a son who was 15
and his name was Johnny and Johnny had a
friend named Anna Wingate who was 17 and
they were both staying at the house also
well they earlier they were out they
were at Quincy which was a town nearby
and they were kind of hanging out with
friends and stuff like that but they
came back later that night now what the
authorities think occurred at some time
during that night the two boys Johnny
and Dana they somehow came home from
wherever they were hanging out with
their friends or whatever maybe they
hitchhiked or something like that now
it's not known whether they got home
before their murders took place or
whether they walked in on their murders
taking place but whatever occurred they
got murdered when the daughter Sheila
came home the next morning she found the
bodies now this was an unbelievably
vicious attack all of the victims had
been stabbed and bludgeoned they were
tied up and it was just a really
gruesome gruesome scene and I have some
crime-scene photos I'll put those in the
YouTube videos if you're squeamish you
might not want to look at them because
they're pretty gross so sue and Johnny
the fifteen-year-old son
they were bludgeoned to death with a
hammer and both stabbed repeatedly the
friend Dana who was 17 was strangled and
stabbed now the 12 year old daughter
Tina was missing so she had been taken
from the cabin and they actually didn't
know what happened to her for a while
now the weirdest thing is that the three
younger boys the two sons Ricky and Greg
who were ten and five like I said and
their friend Justin who was actually the
son of their neighbors they were in a
bedroom of the cabin and they were fine
now there's some speculation that
they're like well they could have slept
through the murders I don't really I
mean if you've seen pictures of the
cabin it's been torn down now but the
cabin itself is very small so some
people were like well maybe because they
did find like a little bit of a bloody
fingerprint or like little fingerprints
on the doorknob of the bedroom that
actually maybe one of the kids had kind
of opened the door and seen it happening
and then closed the door because they
were scared or freaked out but most
reports say that they slept through the
attack which seemed
is crazy because of the brutality and I
mean there was just there was blood
everywhere there was stab marks in the
walls and [ __ ] like that
so you know this was somebody on a
[ __ ] rampage pretty much now from the
start
authorities were kind of they were
operating under the assumption they're
like well the brutality of this crime
and the fact that sue in particular I
mean the bindings that were around her
wrists were really really tight she had
been stabbed so many times you know just
the brutality of it it seemed like you
know what they call overkill which
usually suggests someone who knows the
victims because right a random stranger
wouldn't necessarily have that much of a
reason to do all that [ __ ] to you and I
mean I should mention too as kind of a
demonstration of the violence of this
attack that one of the knives that was
used in the crime I mean they had the
killer had stabbed the people so much
that the night the the blade of the
knife was bent yeah right so you know
they weren't [ __ ] around now like I
said the the 12 year old girl Tina she
was missing from the cabin now they
found one spot of blood on her bed like
on the bedsheet but they didn't find her
for a really long time they found her
three years later they actually found a
skull that they later determined was
hers and it was about 29 miles away from
the murder site so whoever killed her
had taken her 30 miles for whatever
reason now when they did an examination
of Tina's skull they determined that
Tina had probably been killed right
around the time the rest of the family
were so whatever reason the killer took
the daughter but 30 miles away and then
killed her either that day or the
following day they're not really sure
why now during the investigation like I
said operating under the assumption that
this was probably somebody that they
knew the first person that they looked
at was a guy named Martin smart now
martin smart was actually the father of
justin the little boy who had been in
the cabin and they were they lived in
cabin 26 him and Justin and his wife
Marilyn and
they were friends of Sue sharp and the
kids now Martin known as Marty also had
a friend who had been staying there and
his name is Bo and I hope I'm
pronouncing this it's either Bo bead or
Bob a day or something like that and
this Bo person they had only just met a
few weeks before evidently they had met
at a VA hospital where bo was being
treated for PTSD or marty was being
treated for PTSD I'm not real sure about
that so they know that night that Bo
Marty and Marilyn Marty's wife had
stopped by Sue's cabin and they were
gonna go out to the bar and they invited
her to come along but sue said no now
evidently according to witnesses at this
bar Marty got belligerent over some
music that was playing that he evidently
didn't like and he went and talked to
the manager about it and all this other
stuff and there was a big scene so then
later on they went home and then
Maryland the wife she said well I just
went to bed but then Marty who called
the bar again before he went back it was
like hey that music really sucked like
you know I guess he really really hated
this music but then him and Bo went back
to the bar so the thing about this is
that even though Marty and Bo seemed
like decent suspects they were actually
cleared fairly quickly and this is sort
of odd because Marty's wife Marilyn told
police that the day after the murders
she had actually left her husband right
she also said that he had a very violent
temper and that he often beat her up now
the Department of Justice evidently gave
Marty smart a polygraph and he
supposedly passed it but the thing about
the Cadi murders is that and a lot of
people there's a you know there's a lot
of stuff about this on the internet and
stuff like that and pretty much all of
them say that it's suspected that there
was some kind of cover-up or that the
cops knew that Marty and Bo had done it
but let them off for whatever reason
because it did seem like the interviews
that the police and the Department of
Justice conducted with these two guys
we're not very thorough they seemed like
they were just asking them kind of saw
all questions and they weren't really
following up on things like when they
contradicted themselves and their
statements they didn't really cut they
didn't really follow up on that which
seemed a little odd like for example
when beau was being interviewed at the
beginning of the interview he said he
didn't know which cabinet was that the
murders had been committed at but then a
little while later while the interview
was still going on he said that he did
know which cabinet was and then but the
cop didn't really pick up on that and
like I said there are some transcripts
of it online and stuff like that but
they said when he contradicted himself
like that the detective just said oh I
thought you'd know like what cabinet was
well we'll point it out to you on the
way back so they didn't say hey man you
said you didn't know which cabinet was
or you said you did know which cabinet
wasn't now you say you don't know what
the [ __ ] is up with that like they
didn't really follow up on it and Beau
also lied to police about several
different things which he didn't really
have to lie about he actually said that
Marilyn Smart was his niece which was
weird because they weren't related and
also he said that he'd been in caddy for
a month even though he had only been
there less than two weeks he also said
that he had never met sue sharp the
woman that was murdered in Cabin 28 even
though pretty much every other witness
said of course he knew her I mean they
lived right there and it was also very
suspicious that beau said that they got
to the bar between 9:30 and 10:00 that
night but then later on he said no it
was later it was midnight because you
know that would square with the time of
the murder more like he was trying to do
an alibi now there was also some similar
weirdness when they were interviewing
Marty's smart I mean he told the police
that his son Justin could have seen
something on that night quote without me
detecting him which seemed a little
incriminating they asked the police did
not follow up on this he also said he
knew that a hammer had been used to beat
the victims and he mentioned without the
police even asking him that he had a
hammer that had gone missing some time
before and that was also never followed
up on even worse than that it's it's
seems like like I said the cops didn't
do any any follow up on anything they
let Marty
move away which you know they really
shouldn't have done and Beau moved away
also he went back to Reno even more
suspiciously just a few months after the
murder the Plumas County Sheriff who was
like you know the main sheriff of the
county where the murders took place his
name was Doug Thomas he announced his
resignation no one really knew why he
didn't really give a reason so this case
went unsolved for a very very very long
time and it still is officially unsolved
but many years later a lot of new
evidence came to light that suggests
that Marty and Beau probably were the
killers Marty and Beau are actually both
dead now so even if they did do it you
know there's no way of prosecuting them
or anything like that Marty died in 2010
his therapist came forward and told
police that Marty had told him that he
had killed sue sharp like he confessed
to the therapist allegedly and this
therapist
also said that Martin smart was friends
with Doug Thomas the sheriff who had
investigated the case who had resigned a
month after the murders and also marty
allegedly told his therapist that the
that he had killed sue because she was
trying to interfere with his marriage
like sue had been talking to Marilyn and
trying to get Marilyn to leave him
because he was abusive and apparently he
didn't like that very much so you know
so that's how that happened now it
should be noted that Marty only
confessed to the therapist to killing
Sue he did not confess to killing the
two boys or to kidnapping and murdering
Tina so he and he never said who did
that now if it was his friend beau beau
died in 1988 so you know that nothing's
gonna happen there either because you
know they're both dead so but there are
so many weird things about this case
like why didn't the kids allegedly why
didn't the kids hear anything no one
heard any screaming I think only
one witness said they heard screaming
coming from the cabin even though if you
look at the cabin they're only like a
few feet apart they're very small they
were just like little wooden cabins so
it seems weird that nobody knew it was
going on people have complained that the
cops didn't even know that Tina existed
even though Justin told them hey there
was another 12 year old girl and she was
sleeping in here and she's gone now so
it seemed like it took them a really
long time before they even started
looking for her because they didn't even
know she'd been in there it was just
[ __ ] like that and you know later on
when revelations came to light that
Marty smart had been friends with Doug
Thomas you know then there were kind of
rumors of maybe he had covered it up and
all this other kind of stuff going on
and maybe they just kind of watched the
investigation you know quote/unquote
accidentally now cabin 28 was there for
a while after the murders and actually I
think one other family lived in there
after the murders I don't I'm not sure
how long they lived there but they
finally tore it down in 2004 I think
just because they were you know sick of
unsolved murder junkies like stopping by
there and gawking at it and stuff like
that if you go to BuzzFeed unsolved the
YouTube channel
they have about a 20 minute examination
where the two guys actually go to the
site and you can see this pile of rubble
which is presumably from this cabin and
it's kind of creepy there's other cabins
still there but that one has been torn
down now there were actually more
developments in the case in late 2016
there was his true crime show and it was
called People magazine investigates and
they wanted to do kind of an update on
the Cadi murders now the case had been
reopened in 2013 and evidently one of
the new pieces of evidence they found
was a letter that Marty smart had
written to his wife and it said in part
I've paid the price of your love and now
that I've bought it with four people's
lives you tell me we're through great
what else do you want now his wife
Marilyn says she never got this letter
but when she looked at it she said yeah
that's definitely Marty's handwriting so
evidently that was the case that he was
upset that Sue sharp had been
interfering in his marriage and I'm
supposing he just you know if he did do
it then he killed the other people just
because they were there it does seem
weird that he left the two boys
live in the next room but it should be
noted that his son Justin was also
staying in the room with them so you
know that might have been a motive for
him not to kill them or not to get
involved in that situation and there so
that to me kind of suggests that Marty
probably is the killer now it should be
noted too that someone with a metal
detector a few years ago found a hammer
and it was in a pond near the cabin
where the murders took place
now if you'll remember Marty had told
police that he had had a hammer that he
had quote-unquote misplaced some time
before the murders so they don't know if
this is the hammer that was used in the
crime or one of the hammers that was
used in the crime because a couple of I
think one was found at the scene also
but it seems likely and another weird
thing is that later on after the case
was reopened
they found a tape at the bottom of the
case box and it was in an evidence
envelope and it had never been opened
right and it was a tape of a 911 1984
and this was right after the skull had
been found that turned out to be Tina's
but at the point that this 9-1-1 call
came in nobody knew that that was Tina's
skull they just know it was a skull that
they had found so this was an anonymous
caller calling 9-1-1 and he said that
the skull is Tina sharp and then he hung
up so that's another thing that leads me
to believe that probably the police knew
something about this or we're covering
it up and something like that because
they never followed up on this 911 call
they never I mean it was on the tape it
was at the bottom of this box nobody had
ever even opened it or anything like
that nobody questioned how did this
person know it was Tina sharp skull
before anybody else knew and all this
other kind of [ __ ] so you know the whole
thing is just really super fishy and
super suspicious so as I said I'm I mean
the Caddy murders are probably one of
the best-known unsolved murder cases in
the United States and I don't know if
you'd really call them solved at this
point but it does seem like for sure
Martin smart was involved and maybe his
friend beau was also involved but as I
said since both of them are dead
there's probably no way that anyone's
ever gonna know so it's probably never
going to be closed unless something
crazy happens and it turns out it was
some totally random other person but I'm
kind of doubting that at this point so
like I said still officially unsolved
but probably it was that dude but he's
dead now so we're at the halfway point
of the show so we are going to take a
break and when we come back we're going
to talk about another famously unsolved
murder case that has actually probably
been solved maybe at this point the bear
brook murders and how this whole case
has played out especially in the last
couple of years with all these new
revelations that have come out about it
is really really fascinating so I'm kind
of hoping to get into all of that before
the end of the show so we will get into
that after the break and we will be back
in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back I keep saying we
even though Thomson here so maybe this
is the point I will I will put like an
interjection of his from some other show
so I can feel like he actually is here
so here we go
just a so there we go that's much anyway
this next case I want to talk about like
I said this is one that you know years
ago would you come up on unsolved murder
case unsolved murder websites and stuff
like that
as kind of a creepy unsolved case now I
should note that even though the main
four victims have still not been
identified they still don't know who the
victims are but just recently there was
this huge convoluted thing and they
think they found out who the killer
probably was now I'm gonna try and not
mess this up because this story is like
super complicated and I had to get
sources from like all over the place and
I'm not gonna be able to get super into
it cuz a lot of it has to do with DNA
and this and that and the other thing
and there's actually a couple really
good articles on I think it's forensic
mag comm or forensic mag org I can't
remember there's a couple really good
long complex articles about how they
kind of figured out the killer of these
people so we're talking about the bare
brook murders now this is also known as
the Allen's town for and this is kind of
a creepy thing this happened in
Allenstown New Hampshire now in November
1985 there was a hunter and he was
walking around the bear Brook State Park
a part of it and he finds a 55-gallon
metal drum near the ruins of this store
that had burned down at some time in the
past now I don't know what caused him to
think this was weird or anything and
maybe they smelled really bad I'm
guessing so anyway the cops come they
opened the barrels inside there are two
bodies an adult woman and a little girl
wrapped in a garbage bag and they're
very decomposed they've obviously been
there for
a long time autopsy's determined both of
them died of blunt trauma now they
couldn't identify them they were
skeletonized they you know they made
facial reconstructions and things like
that but no one came forward to identify
them they just buried them both in the
same grave you know it's it's a nice
grave with a little you know unknown
woman and child kind of thing on it now
the creepiest thing about this I mean
that was bad enough that they find these
two bodies and they don't know who they
were but then in May of 2000 which if
you're paying attention that's fifteen
years later the police are back in the
same area for whatever reason and they
find another barrel only about a hundred
yards from where the first one was found
and guess what was in this one two more
bodies two little girls like little
girls between two and four years old
these two little girls also have never
been identified all they know about the
woman that was found in 1985 they said
she was probably white or
native-american maybe brown hair between
five to five seven and she had a lot of
dental work now interestingly two of the
little girls were maternally related to
the woman that doesn't necessarily mean
she was their mom she could have been
their older sister or their aunt or
something like that
now the other little girl was not
related to the woman now this whole time
because this is a very high-profile
unsolved case like I said they'd really
like to know who these victims are and
they still don't know they've done
several reconstructions they did one in
2013 they did another one in 2015
they're trying to refine them and
improve them they're using their dental
work and things of that nature they
mostly try to do them in black and white
because they're not real sure what their
skin tone is or their eye color or
anything like that and they've also
tracked the fact that the woman and the
children who were related to her were
probably living in the Northeast between
two weeks and three months before their
deaths because it should be noted even
though one of the first barrel was found
at 85 and the second barrel was found in
2000 that all four of the victims they
think were killed sometime between 1977
and 1985 so these were very old bodies
they were mostly skeletons really now so
the woman and the two girls that were
related probably from the Northeast
now the other little girl either from
the north
these or Upper Midwest so they're not
sure you know where they're coming from
but one of them's not related and the
other three are now here's the crazy
part and I'm gonna try like I said I'm
gonna try and not mess this up because
this is super complicated okay so back
in 1981 this woman named Denise Bowden
disappeared from New Hampshire
but she wasn't reported missing until
2016 and there was actually a reason for
that and I will tell you why later
so fast-forward to 2017 actually this
month now investigators in San
Bernardino California had been
investigating this cold case about a
girl who had been abandoned at an RV
park back in 1986 okay they were trying
to find out where she came from and
stuff like that now she's going by the
name Lisa Jensen I'm not sure if that's
her real name or not but that's the name
she's been using in the press she's
married and has a bunch of kids
apparently has a very happy life now so
she wanted to know what her past was but
she didn't necessarily want a lot of
media attention so I think she's been
giving the media a student him but
anyway so she's been living as Lisa
Jensen but she's you know they're
investigating who abandoned her back in
1986 now the man who abandoned her was
supposedly I mean he told people that he
was her father um and he was abusive now
Lisa Jensen he was five years old at the
time
she knew the man who abandoned her as
Robert Evans who was her mother's
boyfriend and he worked at this RV park
as an electrician handyman type of thing
but I guess rumors had started to
circulate or he thought he was gonna get
in trouble because of the abuse and
stuff like that so he decided well I'm
just gonna leave her with this family
and I'm gonna take off and she says she
was with him for about five years okay
so while investigators are looking into
this case they take fingerprints from
the trailer where him and the little
girl lived
now these fingerprints were already on
file and they matched a man named Curtis
Kimball Curtis Kimball had been arrested
in 1985 on a DUI and on endangering the
welfare of a child and the little girl
was evidently with him at the time he
got arrested so as their
comparing all these fingerprints they
find out that this Robert Evans person
is the same person as Curtis Kimball and
has also been arrested or known under
another pseudonym Gordon Jenson and they
were also able to identify him from
booking photos and things of that nature
now this dude was arrested again
in 1988 for driving a stolen vehicle he
had stolen it in Idaho and he was
driving into California
now whoever owned the car that was
stolen actually knew the guy but knew
him under a different name so this dude
is just like drifting all over the place
like using different aliases and
pseudonyms okay so he was locked up and
then he got released in 1990 and then he
disappears again for another 12 years or
so now in 2002 this same dude and I
think he's using the name Robert Evans
till he gets arrested for murder and
this woman that he murdered was his wife
quote/unquote I'm not sure if it was
common-law or if they were legally
married it seems like most some sources
say wife but some sources say they
weren't really married she was a chemist
her name was Yoon soon-jong and that was
in Richmond California now he bashed her
in the head tried to cut her up and then
left her body under a huge pile of cat
litter in the basement of her house
right okay so the guy was arrested for
that now
since at this point they know that this
guy is the same guy that abandoned this
Lisa Jensen woman when she was 5 years
old back in 1986 they're doing DNA tests
and they've done DNA tests on her now
they discover that Robert Evans is not
her biological father now at this stage
he got 15 years for the murder which
seems not very much but you know okay
and he actually died in 2010 natural
causes okay which you know what are you
gonna do now the interesting thing about
this is that by doing DNA on Lisa Jensen
and it's way too complicated for me to
get into like I said but there's a
couple really good articles on forensic
mag that kind of go into how they found
where she had come from and how she was
related because they had to do all this
triangulation and geographical kind of
stuff and everything like that but they
found out that she was originally from
the New Hampshire area and that her
mother was Denise Bowden and like I said
this woman had disappeared in 1981
however her boyfriend at the time was
Robert Evans okay this dude that had cut
up this woman and left her under cat
litter so at this point now Denise
boudin was not reported missing in 1981
because evidently her family saw her and
this Robert Evans person over
Thanksgiving and he was saying oh they
were having financial problems and stuff
like that and he was kind of able to
manipulate the family into saying oh you
know we were we're gonna move right so
oddly enough he kind of was able to hold
them off by saying yes she's fine we
just moved over here blah blah blah
which seems a little odd for that long a
time but you know I don't know how close
her family was or whatever like that but
nobody reported her missing until night
until 2016 when they determined that
Lisa Jensen was her daughter who was
originally named Dawn Bowden okay her
name she changed her name later on
because obviously she got abandoned she
didn't know her mother who her mother
was and stuff like that but her her name
was her birth name was Don Bowden so at
this point they're assuming since this
guy had last been seen with Denise
Bowden and since he had her daughter
with him who he had abandoned five years
after Denise went missing then they're
assuming that he killed Denise although
it should be said that they have not
found her body yet now another thing
that's interesting though okay so since
they found out since they knew who
Denise was and who Don Bowden aka
Lisa Jensen was and they knew where they
came from and the place where they came
from in New Hampshire was very very
close to where the bear brook victims
had been found in the 55-gallon drums
okay now one investigator put some
things together he's like oh maybe we
should check out a connect
there because this guy is kind of
looking like a serial killer
so the DNA tests on the bodies and the
DNA tests of this killer one of the
little girls in the barrels is related
to him the others are not so he they're
thinking he is the father of one of the
little girls in there although they
still don't know who she is
now after all this rigmarole he had so
so many aliases I mean it just seemed
like he was just drifting all over the
country he worked as a handyman an
electrician and stuff like that he was
just drifting everywhere and evidently
just killing people on a whim so they
actually don't know how many people he
killed they are assuming that he
probably killed the four females that
were found in the barrels but again they
don't know who they are they only know
that he is probably the father of one of
them now they determined that his real
identity was Terry Rasmussen and this
guy was originally from Denver Colorado
he was in the Navy from when she was
discharged in 1967 he had a wife he
married in 1969 he and his wife lived in
Phoenix Arizona and then in Redwood City
California and they had four children
and his wife then left him at some point
in 1973 in 1974
now the last time that his family says
they saw him was Christmas of 1974 and
after that he kind of fell off the grid
so it must have been after his wife left
him or took the kids or something like
that then it seems like he went on this
wandering killing spree is what it's
looking like at this point so the creepy
thing about this is just this one girl
that I mean she's a woman now but she
was a girl when she got abandoned and
this whole thing about her wanting to
find out where she came from because all
she could remember cuz like I said she
was abandoned when she was five she's
like all I can remember is just being
with this guy who beat me up and he had
kidnapped me from somewhere she didn't
even really say much about remembering
her mother or where her mother had gone
because like I said her mother
disappeared in 1981 when she was still a
baby so she didn't even really remember
any of that and it just seemed so crazy
that her wanting to
where she came from and them doing all
this triangulation and stuff like that
it took this long but they actually
uncovered a serial killer that they
didn't know about and they think that he
is almost definitely the guy that killed
those people in the barrels now like I
said unfortunately they do not still do
not know who who those four women are
other than one of them is almost
definitely his daughter and like I said
if you really want kind of the ins and
outs of all the DNA triangulation and
all the stuff that they did to find out
who she was and who she was related to
and stuff like that because it was very
very convoluted they had to go through
all these other relatives and stuff like
that and the only reason that they found
out who Robert Evans aka teri Rasmussen
was was because they used the DNA of one
of his sons from his marriage back in
the 70s to find out who he was and who
he was related to and stuff like that so
but there are articles on forensic mag
and they're really interesting if you're
into that kind of stuff which I am so
you can get a lot more details there
about how they kind of uncovered this
whole case it's really cool because it's
just like this whole mess I mean it's
not cool because you know this dude was
a horrible person who killed a bunch of
people but you know it's cool in the way
that they solved it like after all this
time and in a way it kind of made me
feel better cuz I was like wow just even
though that the case is so old and even
though when they were investigating her
case they didn't even really know that
there was a murder case they were just
kind of investigating her having been
abandoned when she was five and it's
kind of cool that they put so much time
and effort into trying to find out who
she was and and you know it was just
kind of luck really that it sort of led
to this much bigger thing where they
actually ended up solving one of the
biggest unsolved crimes we'll probably
the biggest unsolved crime in New
Hampshire and one of the best known ones
in the United States so I thought that
was really awesome so if you want to
read more about it just go check out
that website I'll put some links in the
description but the nice thing about it
is that now they know who the probable
killer was I think it becomes it's much
more likely that they will probably
eventually find out who those victims
were too because they'll be able to
triangulate the geography and where he
was at certain points in time and stuff
like that now they should also be noted
I read that in Manchester New Hampshire
there had been an another woman living
with him who went by the name Elizabeth
Evan
and they're not sure if she's missing or
maybe got murdered or something like
that because they're not sure if that's
her real name or not so there might be
many many more victims of this person
all over the place that they haven't
discovered and because this guy went
under so many different names and [ __ ]
like that actually the media started
calling him the chameleon killer because
he had [ __ ] he had a [ __ ] ton of
different aliases and along with all of
the aliases that he went by there's also
a lot of gaps in time where his
whereabouts are unaccounted for and
these a clue include from 1974 to 1978
1981 to 1984 and 1986 to 1988 so they
don't know where he was during those
years so it's probable that he probably
killed more people during those time
periods and they haven't found their
bodies yet or something like that so you
know that's not cool but at least they
know who this guy is like I said he's
dead now he died in prison for the
murder of you and soon John who he left
under kitty-litter and so that's how
that happened now I guess we're getting
to the end of the show and I hope you
guys I hope you guys won't forgive me
because I didn't realize how hard it
would be to do the show by myself like
because you know what I'm usually doing
it I have time here to bounce up I hope
I can like and look at him while I'm
talking and stuff like that instead of
just like sitting in my office by myself
and talking to myself like an idiot I
mean you know I'm talking to you guys
but you're not in front of my face so I
can't really see you so hopefully I got
an update they're actually going to do a
quadruple bypass and they're on Tom's
dad and they are going to do it on
Tuesday the same day that this comes out
I'm actually recording it a couple days
beforehand so I don't know the outcome
of it but they're going to do the
surgery on Tuesday now tom has a flight
back to Florida scheduled for Friday the
Friday after this podcast comes out but
we'll see how that goes he might have to
delay it you know depending on how the
surgery goes and stuff like that
although he is planning to come back on
Friday which means that I'm going to do
another movie review but like I said I
will probably do it by myself because I
like to have them up on Friday or
Saturday and he's not coming back
into town until late Friday night so I
don't want to make him have to record a
movie review and stuff like that so I'll
probably be won by myself so hopefully
me being by myself hasn't been super
annoying for you guys
and like I said maybe at some points in
here I'll come you know put some stuff
in like you know I'll put somebody
somebody on Facebook told me that I
should put in sounds of Tom vaping like
to make it sound like it was really here
so I might actually because I think
that's kind of a funny idea cuz you know
and it's kind of a bummer but I really
do kind of miss him and you know because
this is I mean we moved together like
six and a half years almost seven years
and we have not been apart at any point
since then I mean at one point he was in
the hospital for a few days but that's
not really the same because I could go
every day and visit him so this is kind
of weirding me out I'm weirded out our
kitten is weirded out but he's not here
so but it'll be okay I'm gonna try and
muddle through and hopefully like I said
you guys enjoyed this episode even
though it was just me blabbering and
talking to myself so that will do it for
this true-crime episode if you liked the
show please remember to Like share
subscribe share on all your social media
cuz that really does help also if you'd
like to support the show in some small
way or in a big way that'd be nice too
it's no pressure though then just go to
our patreon which is patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcast if you don't like
patreon I would rather make a one-time
donation or would rather just get
through PayPal then you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account also be sure
to go to zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock and
we have some t-shirts there for sale I
promise I'm going to make because some
people have made a couple t-shirt
suggestions so I'm actually working on a
where's that raccoon design which hit
our catch phrase from a haunting and I
also am working on a Somerton Man
t-shirt which hopefully will come out
cool we'll see how that goes so I am
actually working on new t-shirt designs
there's six or seven on there at the
moment so go check those out and that
will do it for episode 74 the lonely
true-crime episode
see you guys next week bye it's a murder
mystery maybe the work of a serial
killer four bodies and a woman still
missing and feared dead investigators
now believe one killer is responsible
for all that horrific violence and his
wife's murder out west
wbz's Louisa Moller is live in
Allenstown tonight where Louisa there
may be more victims and Lisa that's why
investigators want to come back here to
search the very same spot in the spring
where the bodies of a woman in three
girls were found they're also hoping all
this media coverage will help bring
their loved ones forward I took my
flashlight and looked in and you could
see there was something white inside the
plastic bag so I peeled back a little
bit plasticky egg and that's when you
can see that there was bones in there
retired New Hampshire State Police
detective John Cody vividly remembers
the moment when he stumbled upon a rusty
metal drum two bodies stuffed inside
investigators revealing Thursday it was
the work of a serial killer with
multiple names and identities they've
linked the man known in New Hampshire as
Bob Evans to to local cold cases now we
know who the killer is we're hoping that
leads us to the identity of the victims
and location of other victims in this
case in 1981 Denise Bowden her infant
daughter and Evans disappeared from
their Manchester home her family thought
she left willingly and didn't report her
missing until last month last week
investigators searched the home but
found no human remains in 1985 hunters
found a large metal drum in Allen's
towns bear Brook State Park then in 2000
the second drum was found by Cody in all
four unidentified victims a woman
- girls related to her and another girl
were found inside the third girl
investigators discovered through DNA is
the daughter of Bob Evans who's the
father for the rest of the the victims
in this case is still a question out
there in 2002 Evans was arrested in
California under the name Lawrence
Vanner he was convicted of killing his
wife of less than a year
uN son John and died in prison in 2010
and on top of all that there's also this
police say Evans raised Denise Boden's
daughter until she was about five years
old that's when they say he put her up
for adoption
well she's now an adult living in
California and according to a letter
read by investigators she's living a
happy family life live in Allenstown New
Hampshire Louisa Moller WBZ news
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]